c'est un poète qui ne mâche pas ses mots
il fuient les lieux communs et partage
la réalité de ses émotions authentique
exigeant Charlélie Couture rempli
toujours les salles après 40 ans de
carrière portée par le blues en ce
moment sur un chantier un homme se
blesse
en ce moment quelque part une femme
accouche dans le stress
en ce moment un pilote périme le
contrôle
et une comédienne tombe amoureuse de son
rôle Charles hélic couture savoure s'est
retrouvé avec la Réunion même après 1800
concerts dit-il je me rappelle de ce que
j'ai joué ici parce que les îles isolées
vous oblige à regarder à l'intérieur de
vous-même cette connaissance de soi l'a
amené à comprendre les autres et c'est
en duo qu'il occupera la scène avec
Karim Athoumane musicien réunionnais qui
jouait à ses côtés depuis 2005
[Musique]
on se complète
c'est j'allais dire c'est un
intellectuel
un homme de l'organisation
derrière son apparence dreadlock etc en
fait c'est un personnage très construit
alors que moi je suis assez intuitif il
donne la possibilité de de Me réinventer
et
il du sens à ce que je fais en ce moment
d'angoisse isolé sous un masque dans la
logique de ces problèmes le monde se
replie sur lui-même les uns calculs sans
scrupules d'autres étouffe en pleine
canicule le spectacle se nomme quelques
essentiels Charlélie Couture il propose
une quinzaine de titres pour moitié des
champs sont phares et des fusions
nouvelles
quand je suis venu ici les premières
fois j'avais vraiment des intentions de
persuader le monde de ma vérité
aujourd'hui
je sais que les gens en font qu'à leur
tête
la fougue
en apparence et c'est un peu assagi mais
le à l'intérieur de moi j'ai le même feu
et beaucoup de contenus que j'aimerais
que je pourrais écrire de la même
manière aujourd'hui que je les ai écrit
il y a quelques années quelques fois la
forme pour cause la forme change mais
mais le fond reste
homme plein de ressources l'artiste est
aussi auteur de livre peintre et
dessinateur lors de son dernier passage
dans l'île il avait rédigé une chanson
sur l'ancien Hôtel des Mascareignes nul
doute qu'il sera inspiré une fois de
plus par le cadre et la population
[Musique]